my Studios and I'm here if attorney it's
a action RPG game based on Norse
mythology Norse mythology yeah alright
so action RPG okay so long
Bansi obviously classic oh yeah so we're
gonna get into this game so we got Lord
adequate on our podcast all here so
let's talk about some of we actually get
into Saturday
she has
like town
[Music]
that's an RPG
like
all right exactly
all right
yeah
guarantee
to really like them
without any back
have like nation
change
that's Internet
you can't choose
like
what
summers
the other night
by ex-con
I see you kid I'm working on a case I
got the message
sorry to interrupt you guys we press
like free swag backward swags and build
issues cubes magazine stickers stuff
like that
no let's appreciate that
what it's going to be yeah
[Music]
[Music]
sendou parts
[Music]
yeah
you say we get
is there away the -
my bro
yes why there are - eats while you're
doing that people do
you can like us
and look at me - afford an immediate
backer
that's why she's
other characters
is his trunk
in Korea like this
since there's two characters at that
cooperative - no he's just single-player
yeah you would need to play with both of
them in a center point of the game you
can choose if you want to go with the
elf or with the water that depends on
you and that depends while you're
looking for
both of them in certain points you need
to play with fire in December to each
player
like near the end of the game you have
the choice to use her yes so you can
just
he's got cavities
choose just one character you will need
to play with
you know but an incentive way you
not
I know what happened we'll be releasing
for ps4 Xbox one and PC yeah will be
released on September this year
keep your eye up on him and next once he
got some kids come out Unreal Engine a
couple questions
sure